- Well, we have a house full
of single moms and dads,
and a few of them would love to share
what they're going through
so we can weigh in,
I don't know if you want me to weigh in.
But let's get to it!
So where's Desiree?
- Right here.
- [Kelly] Hi, Desiree.
- Hi, hey Kelly, nice to meet you.
- [Kelly] Hi.
- I have two kids and I've been
a single mom since day one.
They're amazing children.
But my brother always tells
me that I reward bad behavior.
For example, if we're at a store,
and they're like fussing
around and they tell me
to buy them something,
and I just kind of give
in and buy it for them
'cause I just don't want
to deal with it anymore.
And I feel like I'm too soft and I have
a hard time disciplining them
and I'd just love your advice.
- [Kelly] We're so different Desiree.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, they're about to be
pre-teens, so I need help,
like breaking this cycle and
bringing some balance back
to my life.
- Oh my God,
that cycle is going.
- It's gone!
- It's like they're
taking advantage of me.
- Here's the thing, I will relate to,
and I think everybody can.
Sometimes they just wear you down.
You're just like, "I'm
just tired of having
this conversation."
You're exhausted, you're like,
"I cannot believe you're surprised
that bedtime happens every night!"
Like, "Why are we having this argument?"
Like, and it wears you down.
So I get why you kind of give in,
but I will tell you what,
literally my kids the other day,
they were fighting over,
'cause they do that thing where,
there's is a little different.
Like they know that if
we go to a store, I set,
I prep them.
I say, "We're going in this store
and you're not getting anything.
We're doing something for
somebody else," or whatever.
Or I prep them and say,
"Hey, if y'all want to grab
something, like little,
you can get one little
thing or something."
But I am big on prepping
them, 'cause if you don't,
that's when the nightmare happens.
And also they were fighting
the other day over something
and they were so entitled
and they've got so many toys.
And so I took that toy
straight to the trash.
- That's what I'm talking about!
- I was like, "I'm sorry,
since neither one of you
knows how to share it, we
will give it to the garbage.
I was like, and it's gone.
- Until they go in the
garbage and get it out.
- Oh, they won't go in the garbage,
they hate that I make
them take the trash out.
(Kelly chuckling)
- Oh no, Joshua has pulled out
many toys from the garbage.
- [Kelly] Oh really?
- I threw his iPad away one day.
Oh, I went and got that out.
(audience laughing)
But I had to teach him a lesson.
He was crying, He's like, "Oh my God!"
Soon as he went to bed, I was like,
"Don't let me forget that iPad."
(audience laughing)